comment ne pas devenir esclave de la
machine dont l'intelligence surpassera
celle de l'homme d'ici à quelques années
c'est le défi que contre lever le
milliardaire et entrepreneur américain
Elon Musk il nous met en garde contre
les dangers de celle-ci et
Justin
pour faire face à la montée inexorable
de l'intelligence artificielle le patron
de Tesla et Space X en tant travaillé
sur deux fronts d'un côté encadrer l'IA
de l'autre augmenter l'homme un modèle
d'intelligence artificielle qui
s'intéresserait à l'univers ne
détruirait probablement pas l'espèce
humaine parce que nous sommes une partie
intéressante de l'univers c'est la
promesse de son nouveau projet
d'intelligence artificielle baptisée x
ETI dont il a annoncé la création en
juillet dernier bien qu'encore flou
l'objectif de la startup est défini en
ces termes comprendre la véritable
nature de l'univers cette IA idéal
agirait selon lui un peu comme les
humains qui aspirent à protéger
l'habitat des chimpanzés alors qu'ils
auraient la capacité de tous les chasser
et les tuer x ETI compte se positionner
comme une troisième option face aux deux
poids lourds de Lia que et Google dans
son grand projet visant à sauver
l'humanité Elon Musk compte également
contribué à augmenter les capacités de
l'homme grâce à une symbiose avec l'IA
c'est le projet fou de sa startup
neuralink qui conçoit des implants
cérébraux permettant de communiquer avec
les ordinateurs directement par la
pensée le 25 mai dernier une étape
majeure a été franchie aux États-Unis la
Food and Drug Administration plus haute
autorité sanitaire du pays a
officiellement donné son accord pour que
Nora link puisse tester ses puces sur
des humains pour l'instant des
prototypes de la taille d'une pièce de
monnaie ont été implantées dans le crâne
d'animaux fin août 2020 neuralink avait
présenté en direct une truie nommée
Gertrude possédant une puce implantée
dans le cerveau qui transmet des signaux
neurologiques selon Elon Musk un singe
nommé Bastien a été capable de jouer à
des jeux vidéo ou de taper des mots sur
un écran simplement en suivant des yeux
le mouvement du curseur à l'écran les
tests sur l'homme devrait débuter dans
les mois à venir à sur le milliardaire
pour l'instant les ambitions de neural
link sont médicales rendre la vue et la
parole aux personnes paralysées ou
souffrant de maladies neurologiques
compte ensuite rendre ses implants
suffisamment surébles pour qu'il relève
de la chirurgie élective en d'autres
termes que chacun puisse moyennant
quelques milliers de dollars dotés sont
cerveau d'une puissance informatique ces
projets transhumanistes suscitent
toutefois de nombreuses inquiétudes
notamment sur le plan éthique la
confusion entre
Ia et conscience risque notamment de
saper les fondements notre relation à
l'autre réaction émotion perception
mémoire seront-elles du fait de votre
interlocuteur ou bien de sa puce
arriverons-nous à concilier nos vies
avec l'oscillation entre ces deux
hypothèses les spécialistes se lèvent
également les dangers liés à la
protection de nos données les plus
intimes quel serait le prix à payer en
matière de confidentialité que Ton se
mettra en nous à cette interface
neuronale connectée au Cloud ce nuage
doté d'une mémoire capable de conserver
éternellement nos idées les plus nobles
comme les plus subversives
[Musique]